welcome back to las vegas now time to
get
cooking with nanny bubby's kitchen she's
showing us how to make a delicious
appetizer let's take a look well
hi there everybody in the studio and
hello to all of you
welcome back to nanny bubby's kitchen
well you know what today is
today is my mother-in-law's 90th
birthday can you believe it yep and we
are going to get together
just as a family sadly just sadly
because she has so many friends at 90
years old
and so much family and we're going to
get together and we're going to
celebrate her birthday
tomorrow in my new outdoor kitchen we're
breaking it in tomorrow and so next time
i'm going to cook out there for all of
you
this is an appetizer that i love it's
one of my very favorite iron garden
barefoot contessa recipes
and let me tell you what it is it's
called the savory
palmeri and i'm going to show you
exactly how to start
it starts first with this pepperidge
farm
pastry sheets and i love these now you
can make your own
but if you could like it says why would
you want to
so we're going to take a little bit of
flour
where's the cup and we're going to
sprinkle it right on here
[Music]
spread it around on a clean
surface which this is a fabulously clean
surface and we're gonna set it down and
we are going to
roll it out we're gonna roll it
to about nine and a half by eleven and a
half inches
all right here we go
[Music]
so next we're going to take some pine
nuts and we're going to put them in
a dry pan we're going to heat the pan on
the burner
and then we're going to pour the pine
nuts in and then we're going to shake it
until they just start to brown
lightly and then they're ready
and then we're going to take sun-dried
tomatoes in oil
and we're gonna chop them up and now
we're ready to assemble it's as easy as
that
so first we're gonna start with the
pesto store-bought pesto
is perfectly acceptable and just fine
because if you need it quickly
because you're having friends and you
want to make appetizers it's very easy
to just
throw this all together at the very last
minute
on to the next step grab the goat cheese
and just crumble it
just right everywhere anywhere it falls
right
just anywhere it falls just take that
goat cheese
just put it all in next up the sun-dried
tomatoes all chopped ready to go
and the same like you did with the goat
cheese just sprinkle them on
such a depth of different flavors
between the pesto
and the goat cheese
and the beauty of it all it looks so
good doesn't it
and next step the pine nuts
all cooled ready to handle we're just
going to take these
in the same we're just going to
completely just sprinkle these
all on just like that and
next we're just going to grab some salt
which may seem counterintuitive because
goat cheese is a bit salty
but it could always use just a little
bit of salt to bring out the flavors
especially since we're going to be
refrigerating it overnight
now come a little closer and see this
really cool trick you're going to take
the shorter ends
and you are going to fold them in half
just like that let me back this one down
a little bit i went a little too far
there we go bring this one in
just like that and then you're going to
fold them in half
[Music]
one more time there you go
now as this comes together and it bakes
it will come out looking like elephant
ears
[Music]
and into the oven we go
this pairs nicely with red wine with
white wine
with a beer and with anything that would
make your 90 year old
mother-in-law thrilled i know mine is
going to be look at these beautiful
savory palmyries and we're going to have
a
great time tomorrow in any bubby's
kitchen garden
so we'll see you soon bye everybody
remember
spread love like butter
i'm liking that tagline spread love like
butter all right check out
nanny bubbe's kitchen and garden on
social media and online
at nannybubby.com we also want to thank
chapman automotive for sponsoring this
segment